[Music]
on this Saturday night Israel closes in
on Gaza nowhere to run for Palestinians
as Israel vows to attack by air Land and
Sea turmoil at the border after the only
route out fails to open I speak with
Canada's foreign affairs minister about
the Canadians trapped this is my number
one priority I'm confident that we can
get them out fears grow for the hostages
Hamas is holding in Gaza and news
another Canadian is confirmed dead you
don't even know what's worse are you the
news of them being dead or the news of
being them kidnapped plus Netanyahu
under scrutiny Fury over the
intelligence and security failures can
accountability wait until after the
war global national with Donna frz good
evening and thanks for joining us as
Israel warns its invasion of Gaza is
coming people are on the move trying to
heed warnings to flee South as the
humanitarian crisis
grows the UN says hundreds of thousands
of Palestinians have fled Northern Gaza
for the South as Israel ordered but they
have nowhere else to go and air strikes
have not
stopped this rescue team was trying to
help others when it was hit by an
apparent Israeli air strike more than
2,200 people have been killed in Gaza in
the last week that's according to the
health Ministry and for Canadians and
foreign Nationals trapped in Gaza the
promised safe Corridor at the border
crossing with Egypt never happened the
Border stage shut there is no way out of
Gaza in the north not everyone was able
or willing to leave gaza's largest
hospital has become a refuge it's
estimated 35,000 displaced civilians
have crammed into the grounds hoping
they'll be protected doctors say 95% of
the medical supplies are used up and no
no humanitarian Aid is being allowed in
I interviewed this British Palestinian
doctor earlier this week There's now no
Wi-fi it's harder to reach people he's
no longer answering our messages but
today tweeted every few minutes the
buildings Shake as the Israelis Target
more buildings around the hospital my
colleagues trying to keep their families
safe while still coming to work have
brought their families to stay at the
hospital every office has a family I
slept on the operating room table
Israel says its aim is to dismember
Hamas and its military capability
revenge for those horrific attacks by
Hamas on Southern Israel civilians it
insists are not the enemy crystal ganing
is in Jerusalem tonight
Crystal Donna this evening Israeli
Defense Forces announced that they were
preparing coordinated strikes by land
air and sea and that there would be and
I am quoting the actual message here an
emphasis on significant ground operation
ations now if the target is still north
Gaza as previously stated by the IDF
civilians will be caught up in those
strikes panicked faces and bloodied
injured loved ones from the latest
barrage of bombs dropped on Gaza the
need for medical care is overwhelming
here and it will only get
worse wearing a bulletproof vest the
Israeli Prime Minister shook hands with
his soldiers asking if they are ready
for what comes next Benjamin Netanyahu
vowed to crush and Destroy Hamas
Following last week's deadly attacks on
Israeli
soil the Israeli Defense Forces told
people living in the north of Gaza to
leave so they wouldn't be mistaken for
Hamas Fighters evacuating more than 1
million people in 24 hours was deemed
Impossible by the United Nations Aziz
elude has been assisting global news
with coverage from inside
he tried to get his family out but
turned back saying they couldn't make it
happen he recorded videos in his home
showing some improvements he's made so
they can shelter in place no windows I
put it down here
there when the Rockets or missiles rain
down the vibrations won't shatter the
glass causing injuries that is of course
only if it's not a direct
hit Israel says it only targets Hamas
locations and officials Hamas does have
a history of setting up in and under
civilian
infrastructure despite Hamas telling
people not to go some did make it to the
border crossing with Egypt but no one
made it out Global News has been
following Asia mathur a Palestinian
Canadian with two young children she
made it to the Border after the
government suggested Friday it may be a
way to escape but it wasn't my family in
Canada right now they're trying to reach
Global affairs
and they have no idea at all about us
and the borders and ra Crossing or
anything they have no idea about
anything that we're going
through you can hear in that exchange
the level of frustration and the feeling
of being trapped as for what happens
next in this war it is likely to be
bigger than anyone has seen Donna my
crystal ganing in Jerusalem thanks
earlier today I spoke with Canada's
Minister of Foreign Affairs Melanie
Jolie from Aman Jordan I started by
asking her about that promised opening
of the Rafa border crossing from Gaza
into Egypt that never
materialized indeed uh there are
Canadians in Gaza that went to Rafa this
morning and had to turn back and go
where they were uh because uh uh it was
not possible to cross so uh I've been
actively uh working on this issue uh we
have the assurances from the um Minister
of Foreign Affairs of Israel to make
sure that safe passage is authorized uh
and we will be also in contact with uh
our Egyptian colleagues and also with
other partners of the region the really
dangerous place right now is Gaza as you
know what went wrong with that plan
today well things are very vol
uh and we know that there has been
violence in the region and so that's one
of the reasons why um the safe passage
was not allowed because of the fact that
there was lots of volatility um but that
being said uh this is my number one
priority uh there are 44 families right
now and uh and and and of course their
relatives in Gaza so I was just on the
phone uh with my colleague uh also from
from Egypt so this is something Donna
that we're really really working on but
I'm confident that we can get them out
all right here's a quote from a Canadian
who's in Gaza he's helping at the
hospital now and he said if we are
principled we should ask ourselves why
can't we help those who are trapped in
Gaza he thinks the International
Community needs to raise their voices
louder in calling for the creation of a
humanitarian Corridor I would say Donna
I agree because Gaza is one of the worst
place on Earth right now and that is why
I met with the head of the UN agency in
charge of providing humanitarian Aid uh
to Gaza uh we met earlier today in
Jordan uh and we are trying to find a
way to get uh a humanitarian Corridor in
place uh as we speak how many Canadians
caught in the brutal attack by Hamas are
still missing and is there any news
about those who were believed to have
been taken
hostage so I can can confirm now uh that
there are four Canadians that have died
since the family uh Mrs uh um uh George
G uh confirmed and there's still three
missing so but I can tell you that we've
been actively involved uh and sending a
a team of negotiators to support also
the work done by the Israelis at this
point what is your understanding of
Israel's mission in Gaza well of course
like I mentioned um Israel has a right
to defend itself according to
international law and uh Hamas is a
terrorist organization period but Hamas
is not all the Palestinian people and
Israeli civilians are important and
equally important are Palestinian people
themselves and so that's why we have to
draw a balance we need to make sure that
we continue to save innocent Palestinian
lives while while making sure that we
protect Israel as a country and as
people all right Melanie jool Lee and
Aman Jordan thanks for speaking with us
part of Israel's mission in Gaza is to
find the hostages Hamas is thought to be
holding taking during that horrific
surprise attack on Southern Israel
Israel says it thinks between 150 and
200 people are being held captive
including it's believed several
Canadians though Israel has said it will
not hold back against Hamas even at the
cost of harming kidnapped his
Jeff simple
reports protesters outside Israel's
defense Ministry desperately demanding
the military rescue their loved ones do
everything to release them Ari Levy's
12-year-old nephew is one of at least
150 Israelis taken hostage by Hamas
after gunmen attacked communities along
the Gaza border one week ago what can I
say how can human being accept situation
like that how can Israeli forces
conducted raids in Northern Gaza Friday
and found some hostages already dead
Hamas says nine hostages were killed
blaming Israeli air strikes again
protesters want them rescued before
Israel's military moves in I'm here
because I want to make sure that it's
loud and clear that the first priority
should be bringing them home among the
missing this Israeli Canadian prominent
peace activist Vivien silver after one
week her son says they still haven't
found her body I strongly assume that
she's being held in Gaza and that's my
hope because if not then she's just
um a lying dead in her house and H they
didn't find her yet Global News was
granted access to her community then we
found her house and take a look at this
this is what is left of viven Silver's
house house the 74-year-old Israeli
Canadian lived here very close to the
Gaza border and she told her son that
she was hiding in her house she was
sending him text messages telling him
that the gunfire and the militants were
coming closer the last message she sent
to him was that they're inside the house
and this is what's left of that house
were hostages taken here you said yes
this Israeli Colonel says they believe
some Elders from this community were
taken host
they found the bodies of other residents
lying in the street Global News saw
photos of their faces smashed in with a
blunt object what I saw here is not only
murder not only
Slaughter I saw
humiliation intention to humiliate these
families calling on Israel's military to
rescue the other hostages before they
suffer a similar Fate Jeff simple Global
News Tel
Aviv and there is sad news about another
Canadian who was missing in Israel the
family of Israeli Canadian sheer Georgie
says the 22-year-old died when Hamas
ambushed a music festival in southern
Israel she is the fourth Canadian
confirmed to have died in the attack
Karen liberman spoke with her cousin who
remembers the young woman was always
smiling and
laughing these are some of sheer
Georgie's final moments captured on cell
phone video that her in the white shirt
and purple scarf huddled among a group
of other young people one of them
bleeding from the leg they were all
scared they were all so scared all these
kids and from the last we've heard from
kids that did survive that were in that
room is that the police officer told
them if you want to survive you have to
run as fast as you can Shear called her
mother that morning and said she'd found
refuge in a bomb shelter and not to
worry that was the last she heard of her
they really had hope the 20 2 2-year-old
Canadian Israeli attended the tribe of
Nova music festival with friends they
were ambushed by Hamas at least 260
people were killed at the event an
unknown number taken hostage you don't
even know what's worse the news of them
being dead or the news being them
kidnapped it's both worst case scenarios
for days Shear's family in Montreal and
Israel searched for information they
went from one hospital to another
parents had to bring a piece of DNA for
them to be able to identify all these
kids so provided them I believe with her
toothbrush after a week of hoping and
praying Shear's aun posted on Instagram
my family receive the terrible news it
is with great sadness and a broken heart
that we announce the murder of our
beloved sheer she was the light of her
house she was a sweet gentle amazing
girl that always loved and respected
everybody around her Karen Lieberman
Global News
Toronto there were demonstrations
supporting both Israelis and Palestinian
I around the world
today supporters of Israel gathered at
Calgary City Hall one week after the
deadly attack on Jewish people in
southern
Israel Pro Palestinian demonstrations
were shut down in France and Germany
today over Public Safety fears in the UK
tens of thousands attended marches
supporting Palestinians police say seven
people were arrested they'd warned
anyone showing support for Hamas a
prescribed terrorist organ organization
or deviating from the route would face
arrest and demonstrations were also held
in Asia the Middle East and the United
States Americans stand firm with Israel
coming up what role Israel's most
powerful Ally could play as the crisis
escalates US Secretary of State Anthony
blinkin has told Middle Eastern leaders
that there can be no business as usual
with Hamas as his diplomatic tour ramps
up America is Israel's close closest
Ally but it's also working diplomatic
channels to deescalate tension in the
region and as Joel senic reports blinkin
also says civilians in Gaza should be
protected touching down in yet another
country America's top Diplomat continues
a whirlwind tour of the Middle
East US Secretary of State Anthony
blinkin in the United Arab Emirates and
Saudi Arabia Saturday putting the focus
on the humanitarian toll of Israel's
conflict with Hamas none of us uh want
to see suffering by civilians on any
side whether it's uh in Israel whether
it's in Gaza Lincoln's seven country
trip comes as troops prepare for a
ground incursion into Gaza a conflict
the US continues to warn others to stay
out of and the West Bank has already
been very uh volatile in the previous uh
weeks will this will we have a second
front here will Iran and its foxies come
in a show of force is one strategy to
prevent that an American aircraft
carrier strike group is already in the
region with a second warship on the way
secretary blinkin is urging allies to
join in the call against escalation and
I know that our countries agree uh that
we work together to make sure that to
the best of our ability this conflict
does not spread to other places on other
fronts the US says it's also providing
intelligence and planning assistance to
the Israeli effort as it readies its
troops near Gaza for what's expected to
be an intense battle ahead you have the
buildings so people will be able to
shoot down that's one thing but you also
have the tunnels underneath so they're
going to have to literally consider a
360 fight what's in front of them left
and right and as well as what's behind
them secretary blinkin will continue his
diplomatic mission on Sunday in Saudi
Arabia and Egypt before returning to
Washington his efforts also include a
call to China asking them to use their
influence in the Middle East to stop the
conflict from spreading Joel senic
Global News Washington
ahead Israel's prime minister now a war
leader how this crisis could impact his
political
[Music]
future in the months before the Hamas
attack on Israel the country's prime
minister was fighting to save his job
thousands of Israelis took to the
streets in multiple protests angry about
Benjamin netanyahu's judicial reforms
that has all now been put on hold the
country is rallying behind Netanyahu and
Israel's government though the huge
security and intelligence failure is
expected to come back to haunt him Eric
Sorenson takes a closer look at the
prime minister's uncertain
future Israelis fleeing and dying from a
surprise Hamas attack militants
celebrating on an Israeli tank a massive
intelligence failure that leads to the
top Benjamin Netanyahu had already
polarized Israeli Society facing a
corruption trial with massive protests
over his judicial reforms and so angry
what he did to us for some isra
Netanyahu should leave now he has to go
immediately immediately and yet at this
moment netanyahu's leadership is
unchallenged opposition leader Benny
gance has sworn allegiance to a Unity
government standing together
shoulder-to-shoulder said gance sends
the message to our enemies and to
Israelis we're in this together the
Israeli Prime Minister also has the
steadfast support of the US and its
allies we will always be there by your
side
Israel is United its leaders are united
says Netanyahu every other consideration
is put aside for the fate of our country
NYU is a little bit insulated from the
Wrath of the masses of Israelis and his
domestic woes are put on hold right now
as all eyes as all Israeli eyes and the
world's eyes are on the uh Israeli Hamas
War because all all the people in Israel
now now we are together we know
that we must first of all to destroy the
Hamas but even as netanyahu's leadership
is buttressed by Israelis uniting for
war anger is growing towards him I think
this war this conflict is like the
biggest proof of their
incompetence and uh I'm very happy that
there is a Unity government but I don't
see a I don't see a future for Israel in
general can Netanyahu survive once more
he seemed to
be made of Teflon politically this
professor suggests he has defied his
critics in the past but the backing
Netanyahu has in this moment may be
fleeting there are very serious doubt as
to whether his leadership will be able
to continue past uh this immediate
events he's going to face a lot of anger
and accountability for this massive
Israeli intelligence
failure nyaho is standing front and
center on the world stage but his future
may be less certain now than a week ago
their country at War Israelis seem to be
looking for stability now and
accountability soon Eric senson Global
News next safe in Canada the homecoming
for people who have fled
Israel flights arranged by the Canadian
government out of Israel continued today
Global Affairs Canada says 700 Canadians
have now been flown on seven flights
from Tel Aviv to Athens and from the
Greek Capital Canadian evacuees and
their families have been able to fly
back to Toronto via Air Canada the first
of those flights landed last night full
of passengers thankful to be back
home we are so uh grateful for the
government and uh all people who worked
the military I have a big family in
Israel and I also have you know uh
cousins um and their children who are
now
deployed um and it's just it's just a
really
sad difficult time we heard the siren
heard the bomb in the siren and in that
bomb shelter we sang Happy Birthday to
my cousin's niece um it's just crazy so
much uncertainty that is global national
for this Saturday I'm Donna freezen we
leave you tonight with some of the
tributes and vigils from around the
world this past week people paying
respects to those who have been killed
on both sides of this crisis thanks for
watching
[Music]